foreign
healthy family units when I've lost so
much respect for my husband because he's
not the father I need him to be and it
has completely strained our personal
relationship so much that it just
completely unrecognizable from what it
was
[Music]
how we doing how we doing this is John
with the Dr John deloney show
the show where real people all over the
world
call in to talk about what's going on in
their life whether it's they're they're
struggling with their mental health
their emotional health they're
struggling with their physical health
they're struggling with staying married
dating somebody their kids whatever you
got going on in your life
my promise is I'm gonna sit with you on
the Dr John deloney show which feels
super weird because that's my name and
it feels like I'm talking about myself
in the third person OG Rock style but on
this show I promise I'm gonna sit with
you and we're gonna figure out what to
do next what's the next right tiny
little step you can make if you want to
be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291.com
ask a-s-k all right let's go out to uh
Celeste in Azerbaijan
you told me like 40 times
azerbijan Azerbaijan Azerbaijan and Baku
Azerbaijan there you go nice job
all right we're gonna go out to Celeste
and Baku azerbujan isn't that amazing
what's up Celeste
talk to John thanks so much for taking
my call thank you for calling how in the
world are you
great excellent what's up so I have a
question for you
um my question is what are some things
that I can do to help me handle living
in a place that I don't want to be and
I'll explain a little bit just move tell
me tell me what's going on if only for
that that easy okay
so we are full-time ministers my husband
and I and we've been living here for
eight years where's here Hide everything
yeah okay
and I've tried everything available to
me to learn the local language so group
classes private classes tutors online
lessons everything
I can barely string a few sentences
together even after all these years and
because of this language barrier
I feel isolated and vulnerable and
unable to add much value to the ministry
I feel like I'm becoming emotionally
unstable I Teeter between this is fine
taking care of my family is my Ministry
and full-blown rage at my husband for
keeping us here
or just depression that I'm a daily
failure for being able to do anything
remotely useful
um so last year I decided I wanted to do
life someplace where I could speak the
language I I speak Spanish and my
husband is Hispanic so we could tune
Ministry in any English or
Spanish-speaking country so I wanted to
look at other options
But ultimately he doesn't feel called to
leave so I've chosen to stay here with
him
but every day is a struggle and it's
getting harder for me to find
contentment yeah
I want to challenge a little bit of your
language is that okay
yeah this is not about finding
contentment this is about survival
this is not about
um this is not you in Williamson County
Nashville Tennessee
one of the wealthiest counties on the
planet
trying to make it with four bathrooms
when you really want six
laughs
this is
um
this is after eight years I've got to
get out of here
your body doesn't feel safe you don't
feel safe and
quite honestly the language thing I
think is indicative of a lot of other
stuff going on
um
can I ask you just a hard question and I
don't this is going to turn all
theological and I don't want it to but
it just can't not
um
I have run into recently more than than
usual more than I have in my life and
I've hung out with people of all
different religious groups for my whole
life
um
and
the word quote unquote called I've been
called
it's just thrown around a lot
and more often than not in my experience
it has become a sentence used I have
been called to justify what I want to be
doing in a particular season and I
always have told people
okay
um
maybe you are called and maybe you
weren't but regardless of what it is
just go full into this thing and do it
and if it sounds like a crazy thing or
I'm being called away from my job just
quit your job like it doesn't need to
have this this existential weight to it
sometimes
um I had a great mentor of mine that
once told me
um
theologically speaking maybe you should
be more concerned with who you are
as you transition in and out of things
and as you are wherever it is you happen
to be then running around looking for
some Cosmic calling that's been hidden
from you so I tell you that to ask you
this question
you have a husband that's watching his
wife wither away before him
a wife who is blaming herself who is
hanging on and unable to breathe
and
when is
um what does calling look like
what's the feeling look what's he
looking for that would say okay now it's
time to go
um he wants a
does it come like a letter is an owl
going to land and start talking is it
gonna like have a vision what what is it
what's the thing uh-huh a clear
um a clear feeling I I don't know how to
say but that God has told him that he
can leave here and also a confirmation
from our pastors
so that's would suggest that he has
placed you third
behind his feelings
behind
um
a group of men I'm assuming
um it's a couple a couple who doesn't
want who would suggest we don't want him
as an employee and maybe I'm wrong but I
can't imagine the line to go serving
Azerbaijan is super long
and so they don't want to lose an
employee and then his dying wife
comes third
yeah
I've been around
the Christian Bible my whole life and I
don't know I haven't read read that
order yet
I I have high concern about people who
are waiting for quote-unquote feelings
from God
um yeah I I understand that and um last
year
I I tried
my best to
to work through uh the system that we
have created for ourselves and uh the
language is very important you don't say
I feel
or that's hard or I'm struggling you say
let's look at options let's see if we
can transition wait why why why why did
y'all create a structure that divorces
one of the most one of your body's most
important signaling systems
[Music]
our church does things and our pastors
do things
we don't rely on our feelings because
our feelings are unreliable except your
husband's waiting for a feeling to know
what to do next
it doesn't make any sense
um it sounds like there is some high
high control
and some High High
um
restriction of autonomy you will submit
to us because we are your leaders and we
know more about what
the spirit or whatever is telling you
and it's more important than your
depression it's more important about
your thoughts that you would rather not
be here at all than be here where you
happen to be
the thoughts you're having about just
running away and leaving your husband
and your family so that you can breathe
all those things
we'll tell you we'll tell you how to
feel later
and with all due respect Celeste that's
dangerous dangerous ground
and I hate to be telling you this
because I know you already know all this
I want you to first and foremost know
you're not crazy okay you're not crazy
this situation sounds Bonkers if any one
of your pastors wants to call me I'm
happy to have them on my show and we can
have it out and if I'm wrong I'm happy
to be wrong this sounds dangerous to be
honest with you
um
so the real question here is this you
can't do anything about what the pastors
think what they believe what they feel
you honestly can't do anything about
what your husband thinks or feels or
believes because he has chosen
to wait for indigestion or for his heart
to beat faster or whatever feeling he
thinks he's gonna feel
um
and he's chosen to wait for a couple to
tell him what he and his wife are
allowed to do with their lives
and so the only person you can control
in this situation is you your thoughts
and your actions
it's so my challenge to you is
are you in a position
to
um find safety in places there and
Azerbaijan and when I say safety I mean
join a dancing class maybe you can't
speak the language but we're going to
get integrated and I'm sure you've tried
all this stuff
um join a whatever group or this group
or that group or is it time to begin to
say hey in 365 days
I'm leaving and going back to the States
you get to choose whether you come with
me
I have thought about that
and I I don't
I don't I don't know if I should do that
if that's the right thing to do
um to do that to him
I can tell you that ends his whole world
what what part of his world do you play
uh we we came through this thing
together I was I was totally on board we
were okay on the same track and things
have just changed over the years and
that's okay
my wife married a guy who was going to
be a heavy metal singer that didn't work
out then she was married to a guy who's
going to be a college President thus far
she's married to a YouTuber and a
podcaster right things change and I
Married an extraordinary Elementary
School teacher who became a world-class
research college professor and she
recently got her master Gardener's
license and now has created like a
jungle in my backyard and it's
incredible
you know what she's planted every every
living plant that has ever existed is in
my in the gardens in the backyard we've
become different people because our
lives changed
and with you if
you were trying to compress yourself to
such a degree
that even if you do survive this
literally
you will have set a forest fire you will
have done a control burn on the things
that makes Celeste last inside
burn under the ground
so that if you'll end up in Spain or
Venezuela or back in the States
you'll just be a shell of who you once
were and I don't think that's fair to
you I don't think that's fair to your
husband I don't think that's fair to
your kids I don't think that's fair to
the people you're serving you're worth
more than that Celeste
and I'm telling you this as a husband at
least for me
I would much rather have a different job
and a whole wife than the other way
around
and I challenge any husband
any husband
worth their salt to flip that equation
on me
no bro I'd rather have a great job and
feel the right feelings in my guts and
have my wife just slowly wither away
that's insane
so here's what I want you to do
um I also know this I know there are
cultural implications I know there are
safety implications I know there are
financial implications there's a lot
here and it is easy for me as a 200
pound six foot male just to start
cranking things out you need to do this
you need to do this
there's a lot of scary things between
you and just walking the streets of St
Louis right
yeah a lot I know that okay
I want you to do the hard work of
writing down maybe for the first time
here's what I want
and here's what I need
what I need for me to feel safe what I
need from you me to feel whole what I
need for me to to continue in this
marriage
here's what I want from me here's what I
want for my kids
here's what I want for my marriage
and I want you to sit with that for a
bit
and if you're spiritually LED pray over
that for a bit
and then from those needs and from those
wants will come some pretty clear
boundaries
Christmas 2023
I am moving
with all of my heart and soul I hope you
move with me
and maybe God's speaking through me
husband
this is the message you were looking for
ta-da
it just looks like Celeste not
indigestion whatever feeling you think
is coming
it doesn't have to be Christmas it
doesn't have it can be whenever
um
but I want you to spend some time with
you and if possible
not the couple that
I guess you all work for but
find a couple of women who maybe are
former
um missionaries
some women who have been where you have
been and have come out on the other side
that you are able to say
um I need some help I'm not okay or how
did you handle this
and you're going to feel at the
beginning like you're betraying your
husband and private family secrets and
this couple that that runs y'all's life
is gonna wake we keep family stuff
internal not anymore because you're
you're the language you're using is one
of someone who is on a trajectory that
makes me uncomfortable
as a guy who's done funeral services as
a guy who's done Memorial Services as a
guy who has sat with people who are
thinking about hurting themselves you're
a guy who sat with people who have just
left their marriages because they just
can't your trajectory doesn't feel good
and rightfully so but I want you to get
some people outside of this toxic Circle
and begin to say hey I need some help I
need some help what do you think about
this am I crazy what was an Avenue out
what's a path like what are conversation
starters what are some things that I can
do over the next two months five months
six months a year or whatever my
boundaries are going to be
um
but just from what you're telling me
this it sounds like you're done Beyond
done
and now as you're unable to have any
kind of power control over your external
situation you're beginning to set fire
to what's inside
and that makes me nervous for you and
you you gotta hear me say you're worth
more than that
anytime you want to call Celeste
um we're here
and if you want to tell that couple
that's uh hasn't got their feelings yet
tell them give me a shout
we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Detroit Rock City and talk to Vanessa
what's up Vanessa
Hi how are you partying what are you up
to
oh just
um doing some
grocery shopping some around the house
stuff good good for you that sounds that
sounds more fun than being a podcaster
what's up oh I don't know yeah I know
this is actually kind of a scam of a job
it's pretty cool what's up
so um I wanted to talk to you about
kind of Brewing inside of me over the
past two years okay and I'm gonna I'm
gonna try and not get emotional so I can
get through through this so I apologize
hey don't ever apologize for getting
emotional on the show you're you're a
free free to feel as you wish on this on
the show
so thank you so my question is how do I
maintain
um healthy family unit when I've lost so
much respect for my husband because he's
not the father I need him to be and it
has completely strained our personal
relationship so much that it's just
completely unrecognizable from what it
was
um you know before we had kids
um give me some give me some examples
so um just a quick story uh more quick
bike storage is because it's relevant to
my question so me and my husband we've
been married eight years we we have a
two-year-old
um our relationship was very quick when
it happened we had an online
relationship and within like eight nine
months we decided we have to be together
and the best thing to do was to get
married so he left his whole life behind
his family his work everything to come
and live with me across the country and
we started basically our new family
together and
um the first couple years of our
marriage were quite tumultuous we were
unemployed we didn't have anywhere to
live I suffered connection with half my
family and it only just made our bond so
much stronger was there was there abuse
or was there like what what was the
what was the the tumultuous part why'd
your family half your family quit
talking to him
because
um my father is like textbook narcissist
and my relationship with him was quite
um emotionally just very damaging and it
wasn't until I got married that I really
had the courage to kind of stand up to
him and it wasn't anything that my
husband did it's just seeing how he
treated me through my husband's eyes
just kind of gave me courage to
um stand up to my father and you know
break that relationship with him and
just my husband was just like with me
and for the first time in your life you
you realized you're not crazy
yeah
crazy okay and that and that I am not
this angry person that I am because like
the second we broke connections with him
like I became this so calm like loving
person and I couldn't recognize myself
and you know it all had to do because I
was just under so much mental stress
okay bias of it and so I have so much
you know to think to my husband for it
he didn't actually do anything all he
did was love me and support me he didn't
do me you know so so fast forward you
have a two-year-old now how have things
changed when you say you're disappointed
in the father he is
he talked about when we got married we
were on the same page bring it out Bring
me to now things change over the course
of a decade bring me to right now
so he is very disconnected from um our
child I became a mom overnight you know
and I tried to give him so much time to
adjust to being a father I know all you
know some men you know it takes time but
he is so disengaged he's disengaged from
our new family we go to do family things
and he chooses to stay home and find
things to to do at home and it's just
it's gotten to the point over two years
that I have not seen any growth in him
as you know a husband a father because
he can't just be a husband anymore right
he has to be his father now and our
relationship has strained so much we
used to be so good together and it's
just
got out the window and no one had like
we've never had like big fights or
anything like that it's kind of like
just this call that's now hanging above
us cancer
so
um he's not on the phone with me I'd
love to talk to him if he ever wants to
call in I'd love to talk to him because
I here's my promise to you he doesn't
like the way things are either
I'm sure of it but I want to paint you a
picture and possibly give you a few
things now when I give you a few ideas
I don't want you to take these ideas as
though this is your fault in any way
okay
but here's the deal it's there's a great
saying um not by your hand but in your
lap
you didn't make all of this happen
exactly the way this was you played a
role you're married you're part of this
ecosystem but you didn't cause all this
but the hurt is sitting in your lap
right so I'm going to give you a few
ideas of things that you can do but I
don't want you or any of the listeners
walking away being like I can't believe
you blamed her for this because that's
not what I'm doing at all not even not
even a tiny bit okay fair same same team
yeah okay
it is super super common
for
a baby to be born
and dad looks at this baby
and he's been told by every every
Instagram account every Pastor in his
life every whatever when you hold that
baby everything's different yeah
and you hold that baby
and everything's not different you're
just scared to death
because you don't know what to do
and I'm not saying anything Vanessa but
maybe in this situation he has a very
strong wife
who has a very clear picture about the
way things are going to be done and the
way they're going to look
that's not how you do that you do it
like this you do it like this no no no
no you do it like this how come you
didn't do that why didn't you know that
about that
so I'm very aware of of this and that's
why I have not said any of that okay
hold on hold on hold on let me finish
okay because I'm not blaming here I'm
just walking alongside you
so
and
possibly
over it happens by degrees and I don't
know any guy who has thought this out
loud
but it happens by degrees which is I'm
not good at fill in the blank
yeah I'm trying to do diapers right I'm
trying to to be able to read like should
I get up right now should I help right
now should I just sit right here what am
I like and absent some very clear
helpful instructions it's tough but
here's what many good men do
they say I'm not good here
but I'm going to be awesome at work
or I'm going to make sure this car is
running like a top and the roof is
always fixed and the yard looks perfect
because that's a thing they know how to
do and they can convince themselves that
that's a thing that helps the family
which in a way it is
and then wife is sitting here feeling
that slow peel away
and you snap your fingers and you blink
and it's two years and you find yourself
four inches apart on the couch and you
know four thousand miles away from each
other right
and so I promise
based on what you've told me about who
this guy was and the role he's played in
your life I bet he would give everything
to have a close relationship with this
kid
but maybe he's never had an opportunity
to have a two-year-old go no Daddy and
run away and not realize it it's not
because he's a terrible father but it's
because there's a knuckleheaded little
two-year-old
yeah I see that happening a lot and I
see him getting hurt because when my
son's like No And and then he you know
she doesn't want anything to do with him
and he's like well you see I tried yeah
and I can see him getting his feelings
hurt and I'm trying to remind him you
know he's just too you know but so and
listen if he was on the phone with me I
would tell him those moments sting and I
don't care you got to keep showing up
and you gotta keep showing up
because that will change to something
fun and that will change to something
silly
or a lot of dads try to start imposing
life lessons on two-year-olds it's I was
the worst
like my son would do something and I
would be like that's not the kind of man
we're gonna be oh my gosh he's two he's
two right we need to play with balloons
in mud and soccer balls and sticks and
fish like this is not the moment for
life lessons he's absorbing life lessons
from me at the at the at the
mitochondrial level but my explaining
crap to my two-year-olds is no good and
all I have to say is this
often men find themselves
in these moments with their tool kit and
it only has three Tools in it one of
them is was given to them by their their
dad
and their dad also gave him four other
ones that they threw out because they
were no good
and it's really really frustrating for a
wife
who has a very clear picture of how she
wants this thing to look
and so the only path forward is not this
moment of my husband sucks he's not the
man I wanted him to be he's not the dad
I want him to be
it's an understanding that every single
moment of your life is different now
what was is now over
it's gone
and that's not a bad thing because what
you can rebuild and what you can become
would be can be infinitely better than
what was you thought it was fun just
having this cool fun relationship where
you all made out all the time and y'all
just went out to eat all the time and
all that that was awesome
yeah
you can have that times a hundred when
you have a kid you've got you're doing
life together you're building something
amazing together he's coming home dead
asleep because he's so tired from
working so hard and you are coming home
and you're dead asleep from Raising kid
all the stuff it's this beautiful thing
here's here's um
here's my path forward if I was you okay
okay I would take him out
and say we're gonna go eat somewhere and
I want you to get a babysitter
so it's just y'all too
and I want you to be open about the
things that you wish you could have back
now
again please know in not one ounce am I
blaming you for any of this zero
but I want you I want you to be the
person who lights the fire for this
thing to move forward
and if you sit down and and y'all go to
breakfast together and you plan on
spending three or four hours at this
restaurant and you're gonna create begin
to build a blueprint for this new life
because now you've got kids
and you sit down at that table and say
you're not being the dad you're not
being the husband you're not being the
man that I knew then he has to throw a
wall up to defend himself right right so
at that point
it was sent to anything yeah he checks
up and you probably have done that
before right
maybe maybe one whatever so here's what
I want you to do I want you to sit down
and say
I'm sorry
if I could do this all over again the
moment I found that I was pregnant we
would have been right here at this very
table dreaming about what our life could
look like together and here's my picture
of being a parent what's your picture of
being a parent and what scares you about
being a dad and what are things that you
don't have any idea what's coming
because Vanessa I'm telling you I was a
pretty plugged in Dad I really wanted to
be good at it and I had no idea about
how some of this stuff worked
and I went to the internet to try to
find things there's not a lot of help
for dads to be helpful around the house
and then I went to some of the Christian
literature and it's trash it's nonsense
it's awful and so I got stuck and then I
decided I'm just going to be so great at
work I'm gonna be amazing at work
because I I'll make a bunch of money for
my family
and so I'm very good talking points
um
if if you could re-do it again what
would you do differently you know from
the beginning but you go first you say I
would have been more clear I would have
told you oh my gosh kids kids poop 400
times a day and until the kids about
three they're gonna toggle between lots
of hugs and lots of no dad no and it's
not personal they're just a bundle of
nerves
and so when they say no dad and they run
away then you can say Here Comes they
can be turned into some silly game
yeah or you can just get a hose and go
pour it outside in your backyard until
it just turns into a small mud hole and
dad can just plop down in it in his
shorts
and the kid will just sit down and y'all
can smear mud all over each other and
that kid will tell that story at his
funeral because he'll see the pictures
he won't remember it right it's it's
it's both completely recalibrating this
thing with very clear Direction and
instruction
and maybe you give him permission to say
how have I made this hard for you
husband
yeah and give him an opportunity to
speak
but I promise you based on what you've
told me about him he doesn't want to be
here either
yeah and then if you leave this
breakfast
with
we have a United picture of what
parenting is going to look like once a
week he's going to have kid all to
himself even screams cries all that some
of the greatest gifts I had was that my
wife taught graduate school two nights a
week and I had Hank all by myself
and he would scream he would cry he
would have just regular newborn issues
that I had no idea what I was doing
um but I had to figure it out
I had to figure it out I had to call old
friends I had to call old buddy I'd call
everybody and but I had to figure it out
and so all to say is y'all come up with
whatever roadmap works for you
and instead of sitting back and being
like he's failing me he's not the guy I
married
let's lean back in with some very clear
on these nights I need help with
I would like to spend two nights a week
just watching a show after the baby's
gone down or while I'm feeding the baby
and you just hold my hand and we watch a
show
will you just rub my shoulders and tell
me that I'm pretty for about the next 30
minutes please
would you right let's be very specific
and if this was Hollywood it would be so
awesome if he just knew all this stuff
by osmosis he doesn't
he doesn't
and if you do all this y'all lay this
out he he commits you commit you're in
and then come Monday and for the next
six weeks after that he just goes back
to work now you got a problem
because now he's choosing I'm gonna go
back to what's easy I'm gonna go back to
what I know I'm gonna go back to
checking out
and then there's a time for grief and a
time for for marriage counseling
but I think based on what you've told me
you're in and he's in and you want this
thing to work and I promise he wants
something different and like I say I'm
happy to talk to him if he wants to call
in
but I'd love for you all to go out and
just say okay we have a whole new life
now we're two years into kid one we may
have more than one kid
here's what I would do differently and
I'm sorry
what are some ways you've experienced me
over the last few years what are some
things that scare you to death about
this baby
as he's getting older or she's getting
older let's start there
I'm highly optimistic for you guys
Vanessa I'm really proud of you I'm
really proud of you
be right back
hey what's up deloney here it's that
time of year where a lot of us are
traveling again I mean I've been
traveling flying driving living out of
hotels and that's all fun and good for a
while except when you're camping whoa
but it can all get so exhausting and you
know this as well as I do can wreck your
sleep that's why there's nothing like
coming home to your own bed especially
when you've got a world-class mattress
like a dream Cloud dream Cloud
mattresses will make an incredible
difference in the quality and depth of
your sleep which is an absolute Game
Changer especially when you're traveling
all over creation right now dream cloud
is offering their biggest deal ever
exclusively for our listeners 40 off of
all mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings listen if you're not
excited to come home to your own bed
it's time to make a change visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
today that's dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code John deloney
all right um so I'm gonna do something I
don't normally do on this show
we had a caller who called in
and um talked with Jenna and then backed
out now when you hear the topic I don't
blame blame him
tough topic
but it left us in a lurch
um because we Jenna schedules these
calls out uh in advance
and as we sat around talking about this
call we thought we're just going to go
ahead and do the call without the caller
it's that good
so here's the question that we got I'm
going to read the email in its entirety
uh Jenna printed out the entire email
for me and uh here's what it said
Ben you need to put some like dramatic
music at the beginning of this that can
be arranged excellent okay
so here's the question from Dean in
South Carolina
canceled at the last minute
how can I address or should I address
the topic of my wife's weight
[Music]
married for 13 years with one child
I love her but her weight is becoming an
issue
she's always too tired to do anything
she sits on the couch and plays games on
her phone our intimacy life our intimate
life is lacking she turns me down a lot
because she's too tired I ask her to go
to the gym and she's too tired she says
she wants to lose weight but then does
nothing about it I'm not a small guy but
I go to the gym five to six days a week
she refuses to go back I am concerned
for her health that is the email
um
so can we do this
can I ask the two women in the booth we
all participate in this
happily yes
should Dean address the topic of his
wife's weight
married for 13 years with one child
I think there is a way to do it yes okay
I don't know that it's the way he's
currently doing it
no but I mean there is a legit concern
for somebody's Health well and so this
email has got like 15 different issues
in it right oh there are issues yes yes
Jenna when you first hear this what what
happens inside of your body
oh I don't like it no no no no okay why
not I don't like the way he keeps
calling her lazy I don't like the way
that he says I go to the gym five to six
times a week and not to mention we
talked about this before they have one
child so we don't know how recent that
was uh it could be she's going through
postpartum depression
um however I think yes address it but
like Kelly said not the way we think he
is so
here's a whole bunch this this tells me
this is a marriage in trouble and weight
is becoming
um the flash point of much bigger issues
so when I read this thing and again the
caller bailed out so we're just gonna go
with our side of this story here
um
married for 13 years with one child this
is a tough season for marriages
you're 13 that year from seven to ten
years and it extends out a little bit
that's a tough season for marriages
um so it's not uncommon for someone to
be in year 13 they've got a kid and they
start to ask themselves is this it is
this this what this is gonna be right
they answer that question a hundred
percent then a Time percent of the time
is it doesn't have to be any group can
any marriage can change at any moment
and say we're gonna do something totally
different but
um I love her but
kind of like the old southern I don't
want to gossip but she's kinda
I said something so bad
you would have made me redo that so I
didn't say it I don't want to say
anything ugly about her but bless her
heart bless her heart
she makes out with lots of boys right
like like anytime you say the word but I
love her butt you just just throw I love
her out the window it doesn't count so
her weight is becoming an issue
then he transitions to she's too tired
to do anything she sits on the couch and
couch and plays games on her phone then
he says we're not having sex and then
she says she rejects me a lot which is
different than we're not having sex she
rejects me a lot because she's too tired
I asked her to go to the gym and she's
too tired she doesn't want to go work
out with you Beefcake 2000 right so
there's a couple things here I want to
start with the obvious I have a friend I
don't even call him a friend I got a guy
that I know
um who gets home from work walks in the
front door and heads straight for the
refrigerator grabs a beer goes and sits
on the couch and turns the TV on and
does not move the rest of the night
period does it if there's no food being
brought to him he will just pull out his
phone and order it
I've known this dude to order a single
Jimmy John sandwich to his house just
for him he's got kids
that guy is lazy
lazy
he's probably going through a bunch of
crap and all that he's got depressed
whatever whatever
that is lazy there are people like that
in the world that may be the case here
maybe
but this wife's not on the phone so I'm
gonna go with probably not
followed up with number two
um
she's too tired to do anything
hey husband maybe ask
not in the middle of a conver of a
heated fight not when she's sitting on
the couch looking half asleep but on a
date on a Saturday morning
hey you look so exhausted
like I want to walk through our live the
life that we lead together and I want to
find things that I can take off your
plate I want to be a better contributor
on this house and your first thought
might be I work all day I don't give a
crap
what can I do to help in this season
right how can I help everybody be less
tired right
um
Kelly Jenny y'all pitch in any moment
here the next one is
um our sex life is lacking she turns me
down a lot because she's too tired
Maybe
or maybe I'm too tired is a way to keep
her you off of her
for any number of reasons and I will
also say if she's put weight on she's
well aware
hey you've put on a bunch of weight and
they're like what no way I didn't notice
and so she may not feel very attractive
right now
because that's a legit thing I
understand I understand that she may not
feel attractive and saying I want you to
come have sex with me is not a way to
make somebody feel attractive right
working really hard to let somebody
experience that they are beautiful
is totally different okay
um
I don't know how long I have to keep
saying this
but men
um
trying to tell your wife how much you go
to the gym
as the precursor to get her to go to the
gym
it's one of the dumbest things you can
do
because trust me she already knows how
much he goes to the gym because chances
are she's home by herself dealing with
everything while he goes to the gym what
are you saying Jenna I get to see you
lightened up in there man yeah I know
that would put me off
um also I just realized too at the end
it says she refuses to go back so in my
mind she's gone to the gym with him
before there's a reason now she's not
going with you more than yeah yeah
and so
husbands are often guilty of saying
let's go to the gym and wife goes
and then he gives her the the Mind pump
anabolic workout program that's about an
hour and 20 minutes and she's never
lifted before and go like just how you
do squats and this is how you do split
squats and she's like I don't I don't I
don't feel comfortable in here it's
holding everybody's looking at me I'm I
like what are we doing the whole thing's
awkward and awful and the next day she's
so sore that she can't breathe and then
he snapped into a Slim Jim and she's
like I'm not going back
versus
hey I'd love to go to the gym you want
to go to the gym with me I've got my
whole workout thing I'm gonna do and
asking is there anything I can help you
with
and she can say nope or she can say I
just don't even know how those things
work I don't know what to do in there I
feel awkward and weird cool I'm gonna
hire let's hire a personal trainer for
three or four times you can go by
yourself you can go on Saturday mornings
when nobody's there or you can go at 10
A.M when nobody's there right and we'll
get we'll pay for child care whatever
but sit down and have that conversation
versus just handing a workout and being
like go get him right totally different
program yeah or even like just start the
com like instead of maybe jumping right
to the gym like hey why don't we start
going for like a walk let's go for a
while just getting outside and go being
together maybe even having that time
together of just you and her and having
conversation she'll open up more because
chances are she's probably dealing with
stuff that she's not talking to him
about because his answer is it up
let's go and that's not a great answer
most of the time
especially the people we love
and I don't know why this is
it's one of the great mysteries of our
world but
um
I have a PhD in counseling you know who
I don't give counseling advice to my
wife
did you know my wife is kind of putting
her on blast a little bit it's kind of
funny but she doesn't listen to the show
um
she explained to me a few months ago
this new stuff she had learned about how
trauma Works through its body it work
Works through a human body and how it
gets lodged up in the nervous system and
she kind of walked me through this
and I said
I wrote a book on trauma called on your
past change your future that
I think bought you a car and she was
like yeah but like this is what I'm
trying to explain and I at that moment I
just knew I knew because I've been
married for 20 years and I love her and
I know I just let her teach me about it
and
that was awesome
and there was nothing about winning and
there was nothing about whatever you
read my book and what because she
listens to all those stories for she's
listening all stories forever she lived
many of those stories and it's probably
not good for her mental and emotional
health to go read that them again but
all to say is
handings like brow beating somebody into
an exercise program is never helpful
maybe sitting down and saying hey I go
to the gym five to six days a week
I'm gonna start going three
which gives me three more days it's a
couple of hours a day
between the drive there the workout and
the drive back
to go all in plugging into this
household how can I help
because I want you to know how much I
love you I want you to feel beautiful
I want you to feel like you've got some
capacity to breathe and do some things
that you want to do
and it's also fair to say I feel like
I'm losing you to your phone
that's different than you're always on
your phone but saying
I'm losing you to your phone I'm losing
you to the couch I'm losing you to the
television set
and I feel like you're having an affair
with with an electronic device
I miss you
am I hard to be around am I hard to be
with
I know right when I said having an
affair with electronic device Kelly
started laughing so there you go
just no no
so asking you can I ask y'all one more
question sure so
is there ever a place for your husbands
to sit across the table and say
I'm struggling with being attracted to
you right now or you've put on a whole
bunch of weight in the last year or two
and I'm concerned for your health
I am struggling with attraction
I'm struggling with watching the person
I love how she feels about herself is
there ever a place for that in your
opinion definitely yeah
um Jen and I had this conversation early
and we have different answers but I
would have agreed with her when I was
her age but now here I am a couple years
later and um definitely there's a place
for that because there's
it doesn't mean you love me any less it
probably means you love me more than I
think you do because you're willing to
talk to me about this but yes
attraction's a real thing
and and there's a to me it comes down to
the way you do it and the reason you do
it the the reason is the most important
is because I love you so much and I want
us to have this crazy sex life and I I
love
I I want to want you kind of thing and
that that says something man because
that's going to be a big motivator for
me I think you're beautiful I love you
and I want you to be healthier because I
know also when you feel better and
you're healthier you're more engaged
there's a lot of ways to do it that are
appropriate and okay yeah hard yeah it's
going to be hard there's no question but
um if you really love somebody and you
intend for this life this relationship
to continue because if you don't there's
just going to breed resentment you're
going to find somebody else attractive
yeah partridge in a pear tree here's how
my wife has done it for me
um in the few seasons over 20 years when
I've just put on a bunch of weight and
I've gained 20 pounds doing this or
doing that
um
the weight is almost always the canary
in the coal mine it's almost always the
indicator that something in the
ecosystem is off
and she has sat down and said hey you
are snoring like crazy and that's not
who you normally are and you're always
tugging at your t-shirts now because
they feel too tight I'm always tugging
at them tugging it I'm tugging at them
and so she can rattle off three or four
behaviors
that I know what the ultimate signal is
is that I'm out of control with my
eating or I'm using eating to soothe
something that's going on in my life or
whatever that happens to be
um and the fact that she loves me enough
to say there's a full picture here of my
husband that's not whole and I'm not
okay with that because I love you that's
very different than oh my God you got
fat I don't even want to I don't even
want to be with you anymore or God
you're lazy go to the gym that's one of
those gonna shut me down and one of
those is
all right I'm gonna get with somebody
because I know the answer good God I
work in this industry like I know the
answers but I need to get on the phone
and call somebody I'm gonna reach out
I'm gonna do whatever I need to do or
I'm just gonna suck it up start going to
the gym even though it's gonna be
uncomfortable for a few weeks until I
get the the thing going but it's rooted
in love and compassion not in judgment
and blame yeah it's all about how it's
delivered and the reasoning behind it
and like I said she knows yeah she's not
stupid she knows she's put weight on
yeah and so brow beating her with it and
telling her how she should do it and
what she should do not helping
yeah it definitely for me it would be
harder to hear
just at the age that I am I you know
closer to like my teenage years and like
growing up I grew up in a household
where everything I ate was nitpicked how
I looked was nitpicked so it would be
hard to hear it but if it came from a
place of like love and like in a way
where it wasn't like you're doing this
like very derogatory you know what I
mean I think I could understand it and
cope with it I would just need time
gotcha gotcha we just need time awesome
which also is is I'll leave it at this
when you're frustrated about something
like this something about your partner's
Aesthetics something about
um your partner's health
it is never a good idea to have that
conversation right then
it's not because everybody's charged up
you're charged up you're you're
emotional you're coming at it and
somebody who's struggling with any of
these issues is instantly going to
respond to that and so a lot of what
you've put on here fatigue exercise
weight lack of intimacy turning you
rejection turning you down a lot of
those things are all like
um a pie piece that you pull out one one
piece and the whole thing crumbles they
all work together on this thing uh they
all work in in sync together so
Dean here's how I would start this
conversation
I'm sorry
I can commit to you I can promise you
that over the last six months last year
last two years
I've become judgmental
I've become short I've become frustrated
I've become angry I've become all these
things you're my wife and I love you I'm
sorry
I'm worried about you
I've got my own struggles and my own
feelings and we can talk about those
things
but I need you to hear me say I'm sorry
most importantly
I love you and I'm worried about how
tired you are all the time
and I'm committed to being a part of
this family and to going all in I'm
going to cut back the time at the gym
I'm going to cut back time fixing cars
in the garage or playing guitar whatever
it is I'm going to be plugged into this
home
I'd love for you to go on a walk with me
at night if you want to need to go see a
counselor if you want to make some space
for being with friends but I feel like
I'm losing you to my phone or to your
phone I feel like I'm losing you to the
television I feel like I'm losing you to
Netflix
and I'm struggling with attraction
that's me being as honest as I can
and
um
I love you not going anywhere but it
would be dishonest if I told you I'm not
I'm not struggling with that too
let's start there
Dean you're gonna sit in front of your
wife and you're gonna hold up a mirror
to yourself and you're going to ascribe
to her what you see
and that's going to provide her
permission to say well this is how I
feel this is how I've experienced to you
and this is what I'm going through and
from there y'all can create something
different Maybe
and if your wife's just a jerk then you
got to take that hat on
but my guess is she's probably not
she's probably just done
and it's from that Ash that y'all can
plant something new that's going to
bloom and flower down the road hang in
there man we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
um this is actually one of my favorite
bands ever of all time ever ever ever
ever
um especially when I was a kid the great
Skid Row but we're gonna do a uh an
elevated poetic reading of their classic
Youth Gone Wild
written by Rachel Bolin and Dave the
snake Sabo
since I was born they couldn't hold me
down
another Misfit kid another burned out
town
never played by the rules and I never
really cared my nasty reputation takes
me everywhere
I look and see it's not only me so many
others have stood where I stand we are
the Young
so raise your hands
they call us Problem Child we live our
lives on trial we walk an endless mile
we are the Youth Gone Wild
we stand and we won't fall we're the one
and one for all
the writings on the wall we're the Youth
Gone Wild
I guess these are the kids like they
want their loans like forgiven and stuff
I guess
[Laughter]
see you later bye
[Music]